[Music]
foreign
if yesterday was The Pageant this felt
like the party
they dropped the coronation robes and
dropped in at the Windsor big lunch
William and Kate raising a glass with
well-wishers including Sue Watson just
talking about their gowns were heavy
yesterday and that they got when they
got wet there like towels
it mean having them here coming
absolutely lovely yeah we're very
surprised very surprised that they were
here but it was really nice of them to
come out I'm sure they're tired after
yesterday
what happened when you met the princess
she shook hands with me
you shook your hands
did she look like she looked pretty we
just ran and we saw we saw them Princess
Prince William and Princess kid it was a
moment for us to just see them in person
yeah we really enjoyed that have you had
lunch yet
after the formality of the day before
relaxed Royals headed out
covering coronation lunches and sampling
Street parties
the king and queen are said to be deeply
touched by their coronation and
profoundly grateful to all those who
helped make it such a glorious occasion
including all the crowds who came out to
support them
said people were partied out after the
Platinum Jubilee but not in Collier's
wood where Southwest London laid on a
spread
Bay a world record attempt a mile long
Street party stretching along the
seafront
and tonight a concert from a Royal
Palace now to a royal castle the
coronation weekend well underway Laura
bundock Sky News Windsor